há certa vez já uns dos séculos atrás
perguntou um jornalista à alencar
quanto tempo ele fazia discursos
memoráveis quanto tempo ele levava pra
fazer um discurso de 15 minutos ao que
respondeu arranca duas horas
estou muito admirado como é que é
possível então um discurso de duas horas
quero que comece agora é não só a
brincar não faz discursos memoráveis mas
vou falar 15 minutos quando me
convidaram a organização convidou para
fazer o filme explica aquino tex posso
dizer que já acompanha até 10 há muitos
anos muitos anos pra mim foi uma honra e
sobretudo o tema que era o próximo passo
eu já dei tanto os próximos passos na
minha vida nunca pensei tenho que dar
esse esse último que dei a seis meses
atrás
qualquer coisa como isso e falar o
próximo passo é eu não posso evitar
pronto veria o que vivi eu e mais 120
famílias
perdemos muitas pessoas eu perdi nove
elementos da minha família
as pessoas mais próximas já sabem alguns
saberão é foi meu filho e depois passado
uma semana depois essas coisas todas que
nós já passamos não vale a pena repisar
a surgir uma coisa muito simples a minha
vida é uma clara evidência
fez-se luz eu tinha duas opções ou
fechava começavam luto traumático
imediatamente ou pura e simplesmente
tentava perceber o que se passou
juntar as pessoas que viveram o mesmo
que eu vivi apurámos a justiça ou a
injustiça com que essas pessoas tinham
tinha um enfrentado e resultado disso
mudar fazer alguma coisa diferente
eu chamei aquele dia foi começa a grande
tristeza
naquele dia começou a grande princesa
mas também naquele dia nasce outra
mulher
custa um pouco falar de mim mas eu acho
que aqui é preciso falar um pouco de nós
para que as pessoas também percebo é que
o próximo passo podemos dar todos não é
preciso chegar a uma situação limite
como como eu cheguei muita gente chegou
e dizer também que eu sou a cara e fui
catalisador de muitos outros rostos por
trás de mim eu não estou só uma sucessão
não faço de uma única pessoa
mesmo pessoas que não fazendo para não
fazem parte da sessão mas estão conosco
e e posso dizer todos vocês porque nós
sentimos da parte de toda a sociedade
muito muito calor muita vida muita força
e é isso que nos move porque nós a bem
dizer somos poucos
ainda bem que não somos mesmo muitos
seria sinal de que a tragédia tinha sido
muito pior do que já foi
então dizer um pouco de mim quem sou eu
e eu acho que isso também representa um
pouco daquilo que nossa quando há um
momento histórico evidência nós
simplesmente tomamos consciência tomamos
consciência de uma experiência que
acumulamos ao longo da vida e que nós
estamos desperdiçando no porque não
prestamos atenção
eu posso dizer com toda a honestidade
que praticamente quase tudo que
aconteceu na minha vida me conduzir o
dia 18 de junho explica porque a minha
família os nossos antepassados italianos
e foram pouco antes em 1890 foram para
região do norte da do vêneto já muito
próximo da áustria decidiram então vir
pro brasil pra o sul do brasil grande do
sul eo uruguai e por que por que em
outros tempos
também havia situações muito complicadas
antes da guerra mundial havia muita
tensão
há na europa se minha família judia ou
não isso perdeu se com o tempo
o certo é que o meu apelido é que a taça
é um deles né somos temos muitos
apelidos para fins decorativos bilhete
até eu sou a tataraneta ou a tetraneta
como vocês costumam dizer tá eu vou
acatar a meta de uma vasta família de
italianos que foram nessa altura para o
sul do brasil e uruguai
pois bem sabem muita gente ter assistido
carro terra nostra ano o brasil do
interior não tem nada a ver com o brasil
do litoral
o brasil do sul do brasil é marcadamente
europeu
nós temos noruegueses joinville é uma
comunidade norueguesa suíça o sul do rio
grande do sul é marcadamente italiano e
alemão
tirando a parte a costa do litoral que a
portuguesa
os portugueses mantiveram sempre no
litoral o interior é marcadamente alemão
italiano e depois o norte do paraná
muito japonês uma comunidade japonesa
baixíssimo vocês terem uma idéia no
brasil há cerca de 80 milhões de
descendentes italianos
muita gente é uma coisa que as pessoas
não se percebem e viu em colônias
nessa fase as pessoas chegavam lá com
com a promessa de terras como a que
aconteceu em moçambique é na guiné
angola embora lá também aconteceu mesmo
se dirigiu então tinha um pedaço de
terra e fazer agricultura coisa que na
europa já não era possível carvão gera
muitos carros a madeira era escassa e
viviam em zonas muito frias dessas
colônias
as pessoas iam sempre dando o próximo
passo tem um caso marcante da nossa
história familiar e no uruguai em bauru
vai a família dela também de
descendência italiana mesmo ela morreu
no bairro foi morreu no brasil mas
sempre o rio douro na sua metade no
brasil essa brasileiro ponto pode
adquirir outras nacionalidades mas somos
é
na casa muitos brasileiros isso é uma
coisa que parece que entra no entanto
por todos os poros mesmo tocadas há sete
anos vem com 21 anos 20 anos e e
eustáquio não muda para outra coisa de
saúde são mais fortes do que do que
outras e 90% da população montevidéu
uruguai vive muito wendel 10 por cento
vive nas nossas vendas ea minha avó era
filha dessa família que vivia na zona de
fazenda
então conta meu avô em conta o meu avô
cuca do contava dos avós dele que o paul
o patriarca dirigiu se então a carvão
para comprar aquilo que na terra não
dava linha sol coisas do gênero disse
então a cidade e na cidade e porque
sabia ler tomar conhecimento de uma
grande desgraça matavam pessoas em uma
peste que vinha nos navios e tudo e
matava estava nessas pessoas na europa e
tentava matar agora num nos portos e ele
volta que lhe eram famílias imensas não
tinha filhos sulfite os filhos pra
agricultura televisão e ele volta a
carroça dos filhos mais velhos fashion
fazenda durante meses e ninguém entrava
na fazenda também fazendo as greves no
centro e ninguém entrava também 10% da
população e que havia no no no interior
um certo é que salvou todos os filhos
não perdeu nenhum filho e as outras
fazendas ao lado como havia mais
contacto com os portos
muita gente morreu devido a uma
pechincha peixe não era uma febre uma
febre muito mais a dizer é se esse mesmo
tipo de povo e migra e vai nos carros de
boi e economizando o sul do brasil e
para esse avanço vindo do rio grande do
sul santa catarina paraná mato grosso e
essa história da minha família uma
história dentro de uma família de
colonos pessoas que vão desbravando vão
sempre chegando a última fronteira
não posso até posso vos dizer que
aconteceu uma coisa no interior do
brasil e da argentina e paraguai
acontece uma coisa muito sui generis que
é a família judia se refugiaram se antes
da primeira guerra mundial e entre
guerras nessa região e depois no fim da
segunda guerra mundial eram os nazistas
também se refugiaram na argentina no
paraguai e no sul do tudo então é assim
mais uma história se muito estranho se
da moçada
mas tudo com muita verdade miguel foi
encontrado
tudo acontece nessa nessa região e
depois disso é natural a última
fronteira no brasil era justamente a
amazônia e os meus pais como bons filhos
de colonos que eram foram na amazônia e
lá na amazônia no meu irmão eu passei os
meus primeiros anos da infância na
amazônia e e foi criada para o preto
manoel manoel como ó e do manoel só me
lembro do hálito cachaça
manoel era uma coisa espetacular ele na
minha mãe cortava completamente bebida
alcoólica é a chance que o que aquelas
pessoas os caboclos tomavam depois do
trabalho na roça cortava a cachaça
esconde a cachaça mas manuel sempre
encontrava ao álcool etílico e bebia
álcool etílico modo que ele estava
sempre bêbado dias são histórias nas
histórias maravilhosas que eu carrego
passar dessa dessa fase da minha vida
o próximo passo foi justamente com
filhos pequenos voltamos pro sul do
brasil meus pais voltaram sul do brasil
e no sul do brasil estudamos e
continuamos a nossa vida já mais
civilizada menos - a menos selvagem
diria eu
eu quando decido também no curso da de
direito na católica de curitiba e tinha
nenhuma opção nem o pt não vou para
portugal vou estudar direito
constitucional direito público que é o
que eu sempre gostei e vou para portugal
portugal fiquei japão 17 anos e sempre
voltava para o brasil produziu todo ano
visitar minha família
quem já foi praticamente toda a gente a
sair do brasil do seu país muito
inseguro pois bem eu levei sempre meu
filho comigo que tinha cinco anos quando
faleceu ea fazer seis anos e ele já
tinha do brasil sete vezes
era um menino que já tive já teve três
passaportes plantada também outro
outro filho do mundo e quis o destino ea
mão do homem que lhes fosse morrer 500
metros de casa
em portugal onde era suposto ser seguro
eu consegui mantê lo devem seguro no
brasil não conseguir manter bem seguro
em portugal mas isso foi o que aconteceu
não sabemos o que se passou não vale a
pena a repisar isso o certo que no dia
18 quando começa a grande tristeza duas
opções se colocaram na minha frente e eu
digo pra vocês não era possível perante
uma tragédia tão grande em perdi meu
filho o pai do meu filho e minha mãe
portuguesa e mais seis elementos da
família não era possível ficar de braços
cruzados não era possível ficar parado
isso não estava no meu genes não estava
na minha história da minha família fazer
esse tipo de coisa e eu caí em mim pensa
tudo que eu vivi até hoje até um curso
que eu tirei a chegar o dia de hoje eu
tenho que fazer alguma coisa com isso e
é isso que eu quero passar essa mensagem
é que nós acumulamos ao longo da vida
conhecimento experiências
viajamos vamos aqui vamos ali se for só
que também pode ser de pouco a um
momento em que nós podemos escolher ou
porque não temos opção e temos que agir
ou podemos escolher fazer algo de útil
com isso eu não tive opção porque até a
limpa também pouco fazia com aquilo que
sabia e eu com aquilo tudo com essa
carga toda essa experiência toda tinha
sabe que há uma tendência da china
procurar conceitos eu não procurei ser
resiliente
por isso simplesmente fui mas é o que
costumo dizer não adiantou muito
resiliente
eu fui pra casa com isso a palavra que
uma palavra que vem muito utilizado em
engenharia que a resiliência é grosso
modo a propriedade que o material tem de
sofrer grande tensão uma grande pressão
e não ceder antes pelo contrário acumula
energia e depois dispender essa energia
como uma vara de salto só dar um salto
é como uma bola de ferro de uma
suspensão do carro
quanto mais resiliente maior é o salto
não é a mesma coisa que a existência
por exemplo nós podemos ter uma floresta
de sequóias altamente resistente ao fogo
mas depois de a herdeira dificilmente
sobrevive consegue recuperar e
recuperar-se ou então levar muito tempo
já em floresta ou de cerrado uma
floresta de eucalipto um cerrado ou
medronhal é o contrário tem uma
resistência muito baixa fogo mas uma
resiliência muito alto recuperar
rapidamente
eu sou eu não procurei o conceito
ele foi me dado um carimbo com pesar na
testa
juntei outras pessoas que também tinham
essa vontade e esse querer ser
resiliente será procurar a justiça e
fazer algo diferente juntarmo nos todos
se não há outra volta da gente vai ter
que se unir e assim fizemos
unimo-nos em força criamos uma sucessão
de não ser uma cessar o movimento fosse
o que fosse não sentimos é nós tínhamos
que ter uma versão a versão oficial não
há versão das instituições mas a nossa
versão é a versão de quem estava no
território quem viveu ou quem amava o
seu os seus e desde o primeiro momento
as investigações
é que nós participamos ativamente das
investigações
desde o primeiro dia um todas as
enchentes as instituições
por isso tudo que está sendo hoje nós já
sabíamos
fomos nós que dizemos e aquilo mesmo não
há nada a esconder um certo aqui criamos
uma sessão que não só ajudou por a
verdade como hoje estamos com um projeto
muito bonito que é justamente as aldeias
resilientes as aldeias clientes é um
projeto que conta com a colaboração de
entidades especializadas em proteção e
socorro e e uma entrada maravilhosa na
base todos do voluntariado de
desenvolvimento de softwares de modo que
nós estamos com um projeto piloto de
vinte e cinco aldeias no território dito
a fazer todo o mapeamento aquilo que o
professor antônio salgueiro diz nós
estamos a fazer agora no território
estamos a maquiar as aldeias todas do
projeto a levantar infra estruturas e
equipamentos casas devolutas pessoas
acamadas crianças 500 nós vamos
constituir equipe equipas equipas a
maneira norte-americana aquelas equipas
vão ficar responsáveis vão ser formadas
equipadas quer a população quer a odeia
vão ficar rising não é seguros rívia é
chamar para si a responsabilidade de
autoproteção conhecer o seu território a
volta fazer a limpeza volta das aldeias
e que parte de terminar mit impões
colocar se desentende nós vamos
trabalhar com sementes
vamos melhorar a comunicação entre
aldeias dentro da aldeia e entre onde
isso
ou seja o nosso dados online e para o
ano que vem no início de junho nós temos
que estar operacionais ea nossa série
que é uma escola primária no olho do
furacão vai ser político
naturalmente nós vamos trabalhar com as
autoridades públicas com a autoridade de
proteção civil mas aqui qual é o
objetivo é não vamos mais entregar toda
nossa vida nossa integridade física a
entidade pública
vamos também nós tomarmos consciência de
que temos que fazer ao e preventivo ea
longo prazo e esse é o legado que a
gente quer deixar
já fomos convidados por óbvios organizou
para fazer uma reprodução daquilo que é
o pouca experiência que nós vamos ter
não há como errar porque tudo falhou
então é só o futuro que o futuro nos
aguarda dizer mais e para concluir que
quando nós vivemos uma situação limite
como eu vi há uma coisa que acontece e é
muito especial
nós perdemos um medo perdemos um medo de
falar perdemos o medo de dizer não é por
aí é pra que isso não significa perder o
respeito é perder o medo e quando nós
perdemos o medo assuntos livres
[Aplausos]
[Música]